c'est l'émoi au quartier jaussaud de
rivière pilote depuis l'annnonce du
décès du petit mehdi dans
l'établissement où il était scolarisé
une délégation emmenée par le recteur
est venu mettre en place une cellule
psychologique destinée aux parents mais
aussi à la communauté scolaire très
affectés à ce propos je vous propose
d'écouter le recteur on avait pris la
décision d'ailleurs avec le procureur et
le préfet de mettre en place dès ce
matin même si l'école ferme et cette
cellule pour accueillir les éventuelles
personnes qui viendraient à l'école ce
qui a été le cap ce qui est des agents
sont venus ce matin et je voulais
évidemment faire le point avec la
directrice qui est son choc comme
l'ensemble du personnel de cette école
et mettre en place surtout les aussi le
suivi psychologique demain et
vendredi au minimum depuis ce matin
parents enseignants tous les membres de
la communauté scolaire de cet
établissement défilent pour venir se
confier auprès de cette cellule
psychologique qui sera en place au moins
jusqu'à demain